a cumulative sorry a continuous
probability function is given by then
they give you a function here let's go
ahead and write that down f of X equals
4x cubed on 255 its defined in a certain
domain from 1 to 4 sold write that down
and then it's 0 everywhere else and then
they start asking some stuff the first
thing is what is this cumulative
distribution function what is the CDF
okay so here comes Part A to find the
CDF I'm just going to go back to my
definition first which is right over
here okay so it's the integral from your
start value to whatever value happen to
be interested in so this is a variable
what is my start value on this one it's
1 so I go from 1 and then I'm going to
go all the way up to now look it's
whatever you want X to be maybe that's
190 centimeters maybe it's 170
centimeters maybe I mean in this it goes
from 1 to 4 so I don't know what this
actually represents but X is going to be
somewhere in there okay so I'm gonna go
from 1 to X ok now good question why not
fall if I put 4 in here if I put 4 in
here and then started to integrate right
you already know what the answer will be
if I go from the start to the end and on
all the probabilities I'll just get one
I'll just get one something has gone
wrong okay stay with me guys and this is
part of why we're like all new letters
here what's up with that right the X is
a variable we'll put some particular
values for X later on but for now it's
meant to be anything so it stays as a
printing rule okay now the next thing
that happens is f of T so see how they
gave us an f of X I'm gonna write that
but with T's instead of X's so here it
comes
4t cubed on 255 so it's the same old
function I'm just dressing it up
slightly differently since it's all in
T's now I'm gonna integrate with respect
to T okay
all right now we're actually ready to do
the integration so here is going to be
my primitive 4t cubed what's going to
happen to that T cubed it's gonna become
T to power 4 and then I divide by I've
divided by 4 right well that division by
4 will cancel with the 4 that's already
there is that okay yep so I'll get T to
the power of 4 like you told me
/ 255 which is already there okay yes so
in some ways there's an extra bit here
there's the 4 that was there originally
but then I have to divide by 4 when I
integrate so those 4s cancel
is that alright so far so good except I
need some boundaries we already decided
the boundaries on the first line so it's
from 1 all the way up to X cool all
right so that 1 over 255 is just a
constant coefficient so I'm going to
take it out the front 1 / 255 and then
he come my upper and lower boundaries
what is my upper boundary it's it's X so
you're like oh T to the 4 becomes X to
the 4 I've already done the / 255 is
already on the front and then here comes
the lower boundary the lower boundary is
just 1 so wonderful for of course is 1
that's it that is the cumulative
distribution function you that was so
bad okay that wasn't complicated okay
now the whole point of finding this is
you know how we're looking all those
concepts that you're doing before mean
probability all that right you have to
integrate at some point so this is the
integration done and now when I have a
look at these next questions I just take
this which is kind of like the
integrations already baked into this and
then I use it to work out these next
probabilities I think is what we're
asking them use the CDF to find P of X
is less than or equal to 3
okay hmm come over here with me
and have a look at how we defined the
cumulative distribution function it's
the probability of whatever up to
including your particular value which in
this one is 3 very good so I'm gonna say
yeah this is gonna go from one to three
but I've kind of already done this stuff
right do you see that like oh you guys
did all the integration so I'm just
gonna put three into the X do you see
that there goes the three into the X so
it's one over 255 3 to the power 4 minus
1 so let me just make that a little more
obvious there goes the 3 being
substituted into the 1 any spot where
there's a little X that was the little X
that I was interesting this time
last I checked 3 the power of 4 is a 1
anyone so anyone take away 1 is 80 that
must simplify they're both factors of 5
what's what's that become 16 cool 51
done that's it so what does this mean
right this is the probability so it's
not a minus sign that's a . this is the
probability of everything up to and
including 3 so you know how I'm defined
from 1 to 4 so from 1 to 3 this is the
probability I guess this is not very
probable
I guess there's more probability on the
3 to 4 section that make sense let's
quickly have a go at Part C I'm gonna
run out of space but we can start the
question it says use this same method to
find the probability of 1 point 5 2 is
it 3 it's just a three point one three
point one just just to mess with you
okay
so what's the probability here how do we
use this cumulative density function
well what I should point out is I might
do it up here actually because we don't
like to continue writing CDF every
single time we indicate it with a
capital F which is notation we've used
before it means that like the primitive
right so how do I use this guy to find
out this well imagine if this was the
question right X is less than or equal
to three point one okay we know how to
find that we would just say put in three
point one into your cumulative
distribution function that would find
out that it's not okay but you're like
now I don't want the stuff beneath one
point five
I don't want all those probabilities
because I want to exclude them right so
that's okay I will just subtract all
those probabilities from 1.5 and before
so that's F of 1.5 does that make sense
so this is everything from the start to
3.1 this is everything from the start to
1.5 so the difference between those is
the part that you're interested in if
you're me to draw this out for you right
Here I am from 1 to 4 and the part that
I'm really interested in is from 1.5 to
3.1 in this case okay so what I'm going
to do I'll come to a question in a
second
no II I'm going to work out this part
that's this guy here and then I'm gonna
subtract this part which is this guy
here do you see what we're doing you can
go ahead and you can work out that value
mowie did you still have a question or
that's a very very good question I will
answer that question as soon as you got
an answer to this because that's a good
question to ask have a go can you guys
work that out for me get me a number and
then we'll answer I always questioned so
have a look at this line up here it's my
immediately following one this top one
is f three point one and this one's f
one point five this is really weird for
me because I'm into photography and this
all sounds like photography talk anyway
it doesn't matter now when you go ahead
and look at these two lines because
you've got the cumulative distribution
function happening once and then it
happens again do you notice this part
here and this part here they're just
which cancel don't they right which
leaves you with this now some of you
will look at this and say wait a second
this is kind of moiez question even
though he didn't say it in so many words
if you have a look at this this is
basically just the integral from one
point five to three point one of our
original probability density function
right in fact if we'd asked you to work
out that probability sorry previous
question if we actually work out that
probability without saying anything
about all this cumulative
distribution stuff that's the way you
would have done it and these two
expressions are equivalent but the point
is like you're gonna be integrating so
frequently but often we will ask you hey
just just go ahead and find that
cumulative distribution function and
then use it and for questions like the
one we're about to have a look at on
that new piece of paper it ends up being
an easier way to go about it and then
you get your answer what was it zero
point three four to three and more
decimal places but we'll just we'll just
round off you okay with that